she's somebody with a particular view on
this she lost her 18 year old daughter
ruby to cancer just before this happened
on the 15th of may emma thank you so
much for talking to us today um
what are your feelings today i mean
clearly anger in the house of commons
about this um about the fact that there
appears to have been a party uh for up
to 100 people five days after your
daughter passed away
yes well i think
there have been so many of these now um
and
it's just it's incredibly insulting and
i think it just makes a very horrible
situation
just that bit worse
um and i think what's particularly
infuriating now is that the evidence
is really mounting
and it really feels as though it's time
for the prime minister to just put his
hand up and accept and acknowledge that
what they did was wrong and it was it
was very very wrong and it was very very
insulting to all those people all those
families like ourselves who made
enormous sacrifices and whose end of
life was made that much more painful
because of the restrictions
tell us what the last few days were like
with your daughter
so ruby she didn't die of covid she died
of blood cancer and she'd been treated
for about 10 months most of which was as
an inpatient in hospital
and until three weeks before she died we
thought she was going to get better
but she came home um
from hospital at the end of february and
then was under regular checkups and did
a checkup on the 23rd of april they
found that the council had come back and
by that stage she was out of options
before she got sick she was a perfectly
healthy happy teenager halfway through
her sixth form
and with plans to go out and save the
world so on the 23rd of april she she
found out that the cancer had come back
we knew she was going to die we didn't
know how long it would take as it turns
out it was very quick it was only three
weeks later that she died
we were lucky in that she was at home so
she was able to be with me and her
father and her sister but we were the
only people other than hospice care
staff
who came in to look after her who she
could see during that time so she
couldn't see her friends she couldn't
see her grandparents
they had to say goodbye to her on zoom
[Music]
and we did that because those are the
rules it was a really really strict time
of lockdown then you could only meet one
person outside
and we followed the rules because it was
really important
and we didn't begrudge doing that
because we knew it was it was what
everybody had to do there were no
exceptions
and now it would appear that those rules
were for everybody except for
the government except for number 10
and it's just
so maddening that they weren't following
their own rules it makes me very very
cross
you seem really calm about it i'm not
quite sure i'd be quite as calm as you
are being um
how hard was it for you you've lost your
daughter i mean this is the wrong order
of things isn't it and presumably you
weren't able to be around your parents
to comfort you
yes absolutely i mean
the pain of losing a child is is
indescribable is i think it's the worst
worst pain anyone can go through
and it was painful for so many people it
was extremely painful for my parents and
for her friends and the fact that we
couldn't come together we couldn't come
together to comfort each other just made
it a lot worse it was excruciating
how was the funeral
so we actually chose not to have a
funeral so ruby had been very organized
in her last three weeks um she left us a
list of things she wanted us to do
and she said actually when it came to a
funeral she wasn't bothered by what we
did she said i'm not going to be there i
want you to do whatever works best for
you
and we felt because the rules at the
time were a maximum of 10 people
socially distanced we didn't feel that
would offer any comfort or solace to
anyone i didn't want to put ruby's
sister through that i didn't want to put
my parents through that
so we thought we'd wait until we could
do something later on and then we
quickly realized that was we were going
to be waiting a long time so we ended up
doing three very tiny events when the
rules were relaxed to allow six people
to come together
um but it was it wasn't the big
coming together the big celebration of
life that we'd hoped for and i think
that has made the grieving process a lot
harder for everybody not just for us
and when you think back now to that time
and how incredibly difficult
it was for you
um what would your message to the
government be today
well my message would be
i think you owe us an apology
um it's very very clear that you broke
the rules
it would appear that you don't care that
you broke the rules and i feel very
strongly that we deserve leaders who
will lead by example
we deserve better than this
and it's funny that you said i i seem
very calm about this i i am boiling with
rage inside and if ruby were alive now
she would be absolutely spitting mad
she asked to be remembered by the motto
live kindly live loudly she believed
that being kind
is the most important thing but she also
believed very strongly in calling out
injustice and standing up for what you
believe in which is where the loudly
part of her motto comes from um and she
would not be calm if she was allowed
alive right now she would have made a
protest banner and she'd be banging on
the gates of number 10 and absolutely
furious
so i'm doing this interview for her this
is me living loudly on her behalf
because she would want me to talk up
about this
do you think the government is operating
to to a different set of rules
than the ones that you operated to
absolutely absolutely i think it was
mentioned by somebody just now in the
houses of parliament it's one rule for
them one rule for everybody else and
that's just not acceptable it's not good
enough um it's frankly outrageous and
it's time for them to to confess and and
to apologize
how hard was it for you to stick to the
rules i mean obviously you did um
but there must have been moments when
you just thought i i really want my
parents around me now or
ruby really deserves to have her friends
around her now
yes i mean it was very hard thank
heavens for technology um and actually
the fact that um so ruby should have
been taking her a-levels that summer and
the fact that for her friends you know
it was the first year where all the
exams were cancelled so
had there been exams her friends would
have literally just been starting to set
their a level exams as she died as it
was they weren't sitting exams so they
were available
to talk to her a lot on zoom there were
a lot of online house parties that she
took part in so she was able to be
connected with her friends but it's just
not the same as seeing people in person
um and it was it was very hard what we
did after she died is we actually
created a bit of a
memorial garden in our front garden with
banners and flowers and we invited
people to come past and leave little
notes about what they remembered about
ruby and that became a very beautiful
thing so people came through in their
family groups in pairs under the rules
but there was a constant stream of
people coming through our front garden
which was really the best the best that
we could do the best that we could offer
people under the circumstances
well emma thank you for for talking to
us today and telling us all about ruby
and i'm really sorry for your loss thank
you very much